[Musik]
silvia und neu delhi auf dem weg zu
ihrem lager eine matratze unter planen
ihr gesamter besitz in ein paar taschen
auf engstem raum mit dutzenden anderen
mutter silvia und ihre achtjährige
tochter kommen aus guatemala aber seit
drei monaten sind sie hier in reynosa
mexiko direkt an der grenze zu den usa
ich versuche so zu tun als sei das alles
ein abenteuer tochter wir gehen auf
reisen lernen neue dinge kennen aber sie
lässt sich nichts vormachen
du nennst das ein abenteuer auf dem
boden schlafen von spenden leben in
wirklichkeit sind sie auf der flucht
die familie wurde von gangs erpresst
dann wurden ag lyss vater ermordet
silvia wollte sich und ihre tochter in
sicherheit bringen
in die usa doch ihr versucht die grenze
zu überqueren scheiterte die us behörden
schoben sie ab zurück nach mexiko
seitdem sind sie hier doch auch das camp
ist kontrolliert vom organisierten
verbrechen kidnappings und erpressungen
sind an der tagesordnung die kartelle
wissen dass niemand die flüchtlinge
schützt silvia hat wieder angst um lily
wir mütter schlafen nachts nicht richtig
weil wir angst haben dass man unsere
kinder cloud deshalb haben wir uns
organisiert die eine hälfte schläft die
andere bleibt wach und passt auf silvia
lässt ihre tochter nicht aus den augen
den ganzen tag sitzt sie im takko laden
wo die mutter arbeitet immer in
sichtweite auf dauer das weiß silvia
kann sinai hier nicht beschützen
sie sieht nur eine lösung das kind
alleine über die grenze zu schicken
sie ist meine einzige tochter sie ist
alles was ich habe
sie ist der grund warum ich hier bin wir
haben doch nur uns wir waren noch nie
getrennt egal was passierte
trennung aus verzweiflung viele mütter
haben diesen schritt bereits getan
rückblick 2018
diese bilder gingen um die welt kinder
in käfigen donald trump ließ
asylsuchende familien an der grenze
trennen politik der abschreckung der
regierungswechsel in washington erweckte
hoffnungen präsident biden signalisierte
gleich zu anfang seiner amtszeit dass er
für eine humanere immigrationspolitik
steht
er stoppte die abschiebung von
minderjährigen die unbeabsichtigte folge
wieder getrennte familien wieder volle
auffanglager allein im monat april kamen
17 1171 kinder
wir sind nachts am ufer des rio grande
in texas unterwegs
allein an dieser einen stelle entlang
der über 3000 kilometer langen grenze
zwischen den usa und mexiko überqueren
jede nacht dutzende in schlauchbooten
der schlepper den fluss helfer einer
kirchengemeinde verteilen wasser geben
den menschen das gefühl willkommen zu
sein in amerika michelle betet mit ihnen
aber sie war es dass viele wieder
zurückgeschickt werden die unbegleiteten
kinder dürfen bleiben
[Musik]
wir treffen henry er ist 16 und hat
seine mutter in honduras zurück gelassen
das war hart aber ich will zur schule
gehen etwas aus meinem leben machen
der 17 jährigen julia merkt man das
trauma an
sie sagt uns die hätte angst es hätte
ihr alles mögliche auf der reise
passieren können weil sie so ganz
alleine waren die 14 jährige kimberly
kommt aus honduras seit monaten ist sie
unterwegs will zu ihrer mutter nach
missouri die us grenzbehörden wollen
nicht dass wir mit ihr reden
doch sie sind machtlos gegen das was
hier jede nacht passiert alles ist
bestens organisiert
überall finden wir armbändchen aus
plastik die schleuser verpassen den
migranten regelrecht etiketten je nach
zielort
auf denen der kinder steht and träger
übergabe an die behörden
flüchtlinge denen die abschiebung droht
werden an anderen stellen übergesetzt
dort wo sie er unentdeckt bleiben
[Musik]
das berührt mein herz die geschichten zu
hören von menschen die fliehen manchen
die beinahe gekippt wurden
ich komme fast jede nacht und es ist
hart es zu hören
ich kann nur beten dass gott ihnen hilft
zurück auf der mexikanischen seite wir
sind mit dennis seiner frau julie und
ihrem sohn michael verabredet auch sie
haben schon einmal den rio grande
überquert doch wie so viele andere
wurden sie direkt wieder zurück
geschickt nach mexiko um dort den
ausgang ihres asylverfahrens abzuwarten
damals waren noch ihre töchter daniela
und naomi bei ihnen doch nach sechs
monaten des wartens fasst die familie
einen entschluss
wir trafen die schwierigste entscheidung
es ist schwer zu erklären aber wenn ich
nicht in dieser situation gewesen wäre
hätte ich mir das selbst nie vorstellen
können
es ist schwer zu zusehen wie deine
kinder frieren keine unterkunft haben
leere mägen du fühlst dich hilflos du
hast nur eine wahl mit ihnen zu sterben
oder sie zu beschützen
er brachte seine töchter an den
grenzübergang übergab sie persönlich an
die grenzbeamten und wartete bis er
sicher war dass sie es auf die andere
seite geschafft hatten anderthalb jahre
ist das nun her
[Musik]
ich werde das nie vergessen egal wie
sehr ich mich anstrenge diese anderthalb
jahre ohne meine töchter die bekomme ich
nie zurück das was ich mir am meisten
auf der welt wünsche ist bei ihnen zu
sein und dann kamen sie noch zwei
kettchen hervor
die haben sie bereits für den moment des
wiedersehens gekauft auch wenn sie
weiter um asyl kämpfen schwindet die
hoffnung jeden tag ein bisschen mehr
und so geben sie den schmuck lieber uns
mit denn wir sind mit ihren töchtern
verabredet ein paar tage später in den
usa die beiden regierung will das
problem der migration bei der wurzel
packen vize-präsidentin harris nutzte
ihre erste auslandsreise für einen
besuch in mexiko und guatemala um
gemeinsam strategien zu entwickeln dass
weniger menschen ihre heimatländer
verlassen
unter anderem sollen mehr möglichkeiten
für unternehmer und landwirte geschaffen
werden sowie frauen stärker gefördert
werden
die initiative steckt noch sehr in den
kinderschuhen und im camp von renault sa
haben die migranten wenig vertrauen in
solche vorstöße
die hilfe kommt ja doch nicht bei uns
armen an die regierung behält sie für
sich selbst ihr arme bleiben für immer
während sie in ihren villen sitzen wenn
wir gute regierungen hätten die für
arbeitsplätze und sicherheit sorgten
dann würden die leute vielleicht auch
bleiben
vielleicht
carmen konnte darauf nicht warten als
ihr sohn aaron in das alter kam wo die
gangs ihn rekrutieren wollten musste sie
honduras verlassen
als erstes brachte sie ihnen sicherheit
schickte ihn alleine über die grenze zu
seinem vater und bruder in florida von
dort sendet er fotos und nachrichten
mami ich habe dich sehr lieb wir hoffen
bald wieder zusammen zu sein aber wenn
nicht dann das wenigstens ehren
sicherheit als walter willmann dass es
seinen kindern gut geht
auch wenn man selbst das schlimmste
durchmacht loki virginia
hier leben jetzt daniela und naomi deren
eltern wir in mexiko getroffen haben
ihre tante und ihr onkel haben trotz
eigener knappheit das geld für die
schleuser aufgebracht als die mädchen
hier ankamen waren sie ausgemergelt und
verschüchtert naomi ist jetzt acht jahre
alt daniela 11 sie versuchen englisch zu
lernen die schule
mögen sie
[Musik]
in der schule in honduras hatten wir
keinen kopf auch nicht kunst musik oder
ton
[Musik]
das gab all das nicht was es hier gibt
mein vater sagte die stecken euch erst
in eine zelle dann kommt ihr in eine
notunterkunft und dann zu unserer tante
er dachte dass das alles viel schneller
gehen würde dann laufen die tränen als
wir nachfragen weil ja alles schon so
lange dauert nichts wünscht sie sich
sehnlicher als ein wiedersehen sagt sie
uns mama und papa sind virtuell dabei
als wir den mädchen ihre geschenke
übergeben
es ist ein bittersüßer moment denn sie
wissen immer noch nicht ob der
asylantrag für die familie genehmigt
wird
wenn nicht dann werden sie wohl alle
wieder nach honduras zurückkehren
auch die mädchen
[Musik]
aber tante jackie tut alles damit
daniela und naomi sich erstmal hier ein
wenig zu hause fühlen
in sicherheit in einem möglichst
normalen leben
[Musik]
ihre geschichte ist die von
zehntausenden kindern in den usa bis
sich an der migrationspolitik der
vereinigten staaten grundlegend etwas
ändert werden es jede nacht mehr
[Musik]